hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the Masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies of people who
have already done what you're trying to
do so today we're going to look at how a
young man who had all the odds in the
world stacked against him rose up to the
challenge proved his critics wrong and
went on to become one of the wealthiest
entrepreneurs in the world this is a
story of CNN found there Ted Turner and
the top three lessons you can learn from
his success Ted Turner is an American
media mogul and philanthropist he's the
founder of the cable news network CNN
and is known for his 1 billion dollar
gift to support united nations causes
growing up Turner was a C student and
was rebellious eventually getting
expelled from Brown University for
having a woman in his room with him in
the following years his parents divorced
he got married and divorced his 12 year
old sister developed terminal lupus and
his father went so far into debt with
his advertising company that he
committed suicide Turner was 24 years
old and his father's company was almost
bankrupt but he decided he would take
over the family business nobody believed
the young rebel would ever make anything
of himself Turner set out to prove them
wrong he built up his father's
advertising business and then expanded
into radio and television ventures he
went on to create the CNN television
network and Turner Broadcasting System
TBS he would also go on the by the
Atlanta Braves baseball team in Atlanta
Hawks basketball team to provide
original content for her stations Turner
came a long way from a 24 year old who
nobody believed in in 1991 turned became
the first media figure to be named Time
magazine's man of the year he owns over
2 million acres of land has the largest
private bison herd of 50,000 and donated
1 billion dollars to United Nations
causes his current net worth is over two
billion dollars and he currently
dedicates his time and resources to
making the world a better safer place
for future generations
by committing himself to becoming a
success and by working hard Ted Turner
was able to turn his father's bankrupt
company around and become one of the
wealthiest entrepreneurs in the world to
help you turn your company around here
are three action items you can learn
from Ted Turner action item number one
decide you'll be a success a turning
point for many entrepreneurs comes when
they commit to their business and decide
that they are going to see things
through until they become a success it
doesn't mean that it's going to happen
overnight but it's a commitment to
reaching success I'm putting the daily
effort into making that goal become a
reality stunned by his father's suicide
turn and realize that he had to set
ambitious goals for himself so he always
had something to live for he committed
to changing his path and getting serious
about his life despite advice a sell-off
Turner advertising after his father's
death turn her fought to keep the
company and work to bringing enough
business to pay off its debts as he grew
his business he kept driving for higher
goals to keep himself challenged and
gave his best effort every day according
to Turner if you've got an innovative
idea and the majority doesn't poopoo it
then odds are you must not have a very
good idea when people thought I was
loony it didn't bother me at all in fact
I considered that I must be really onto
something you should set goals beyond
your reach so you always have something
to live for I decided I wanted to be a
success
oxana number two never quit when you're
an entrepreneur there's always a
temptation to quit when the excitement
of starting up wears off and near the
daily grind in front in your business
don't quit remember you decided that
you're going to be successful and that
comes from doing something every day
that will move your business forward
remember why you started your business
and think about all the people you're
going to be able to help find that
motivation to keep going even when
people around you think you're nuts
almost every venture that Turner started
up for every business that he acquired
critics told him that it would never
work and he was spending his money
foolishly when Turner told people he
wanted to create a 24-hour news only
network they thought he was crazy nobody
would tune in to watch news all day long
it was a suicide mission they said
undeterred Turner fought tooth and nail
until he finally launched CNN which
revolutionized the media industry and
became a rapid success according to
Turner all my life people have said that
I wasn't going to make it they laughed
at me when i started with CBS they
laughed at me when i started CNN they
laughed at me when I bought the Braves
they laughed at me when I bought the
Hawks they laughed at me when I bought
MGM you can never quit winners never
quit and quitters never win action item
number three work hard there are many
paths of success but one common theme
you'll find if you model successful
entrepreneurs is that they worked very
hard to get their businesses going being
an entrepreneur is not a nine-to-five
job you're going to work harder than
you've ever worked before and will
hopefully love almost every minute of it
because you're doing something that
you're extremely passionate about
success does not come without the hard
work behind it when Turner was launching
CNN he frequently worked 18-hour days he
converted his office into an apartment
and slept over most nights at CNN
headquarters CNN staff regularly saw him
leave his office to grab a cup coffee in
his bathrobe Turner felt that the best
way to lead is by example and inspired
his staff to work almost as hard as him
to achieve their common goal
a former employee one set of Turner he
was much more than a cheerleader he was
a kind of guy you'd want to run through
a wall for according to Turner early to
bed early to rise work like hell and
advertise CNN came out of my heart and
soul I see what keeps people young work
so remember decide you're going to be a
success never quit and work hard to
finish up this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories about
Ted Turner and some of his best quotes
Turner has a long-standing bitterness
with News Corporation's Rupert Murdoch
it began in nineteen eighty-three when a
Murdock sponsored yacht crashed in the
Turner's boat during a race causing it
to sink only 10 kilometers from the
finish line Turner was an avid sailor
and won the American Cup sailings most
prestigious award so he took the crash
personally he challenged Murdoch to a
televised fist fight in Las Vegas
Murdock declined
thank you for joining me for another
edition of model in the Masters if you
like the video and want to see more
please leave a thumbs up below I'd also
love to hear feedback if you want to
leave a comment under the video and stay
tuned for the next episode